- So my name is Tracie Addy, I work here
at the Center for Teaching and Learning,
and I co-direct our
National Summer Institutes
on scientific teaching.
I also work with faculty
teaching initiatives
and this past semester, I had the pleasure
of teaching a course that was
Scientific Teaching for Life Sciences
for graduate students and postdocs.
So what I want to talk about today
is basically how I piloted,
I consider it a huge pilot,
a tool on the peer review in Canvas.
Okay, so just a little bit of context
so that you know my course.
I co-taught BBS 879,
which is, again, the Theory and Practice
of Scientific Teaching for Life Sciences.
The level of this course
was graduate students
and postdocs, mostly postdocs.
About 16 to four or so graduate students.
But this tool could be used in any type
of class, undergraduate et cetera.
So the assignment that my students had
was to create a diversity statement.
So, a lot of these
postdocs or grad students
will be going out to the job market,
so we have a variety of tools in the class
focused on career development.
And one of them was creating
a diversity statement.
So this is the prompt they were given,
basically to simulate
if they were applying
to a position and they had to prepare
this particular statement.
So why did I use the peer review tool?
Well essentially, our students being
postdocs and graduate students,
a lot of them have this
season of missing classes.
So they had conferences, they
had a whole bunch of things.
I think in the month of April,
we actually Zoomed our class
so that all of our virtual
students could come in,
because of all of their many
obligations and whatnot.
And so, what I thought, was because
we had a two-part session
on diversity statements,
one being what is a diversity statement,
the second being you're part
of the hiring committee,
how can we train you to look at criteria
to evaluate the diversity statement.
And to actually do that
peer review in class.
I thought it would be great to be able
to have the students
who weren't able to come
to actually still do the peer review.
So this was the rationale.
So there was a subset of students
that were to complete this assignment
online, for helpful reasons.
It is a non-credit course, but
they sign up and apply
to take this course,
so they're usually
pretty curious about it.
Okay, so this is what
I did for peer review.
So essentially in our Canvas course site,
I created an assignment
that was essentially peer review.
And I basically told them upload your
draft of your diversity statement,
and what I did when I actually
went in was I paired specific students.
And you can do this in
Canvas, which is great,
with other students.
So everybody was supposed to,
in class, have two people
review their statement.
So I set up the same option on Canvas
for those students who were going
to be virtual as well.
Now a couple of neat things that
I think Canvas can do for peer review
is that you can actually implement
a grading rubric inside
the actual peer review feature.
So I did this, because actually in class,
we went over the rubric.
We went through the hiring committee
based upon the hiring committee of a
particular institution out in California.
So we kind of used that as a model.
And I created the criteria based
upon this and to basically plug them
this into the rubric function and also
added a couple of other areas there.
So what the students can do
when their peer review
person they're paired with
uploads their particular statement,
they can actually see their statement.
So it's a nice window
view of their statement
as if you have a Microsoft
Word document up.
And then they also show this particular
rubric, so they can actually edit
and give comments directly
on their document.
And they can also give comments
and feedback on the rubric.
I was very interested in the rubric per se
because we wanted to say well, would
you hire this person based on their
diversity statement, although
they'd have a whole package,
but would you actually hire them,
and so they could actually tally
the items to figure out if they
had a high score or not.
So what were some benefits?
So, obviously, I talked a little
bit about well our students were
not in class, so how could we
still have them have a similar experience?
And creating it outside of class
digitally definitely did
this in some ways for them.
Students can be assigned, as I mentioned,
specific partners, so
you could pair them up.
You could also, though,
do this anonymously.
So you could do anonymous
peer reviews as well.
Depends on your goals, what
you desire in the course.
Students can insert comments directly in,
so I think that's also a bonus.
I don't know if Canvas
always had that option,
but I think it's pretty neat to
actually be able to insert
on the document itself.
And you can upload rubrics or criteria,
in any form or fashion.
Okay, so there were a few challenges
that I'd like to also express to you.
This was my first time
using the tool in the class,
so students, I realized, some of them,
they needed to kind of
know how to use the tool.
So I probably should've in the beginning
showed a few of them them how
before they went off and
left into all their places.
But I think I just needed
to give a little bit
more structure there.
One of the students was abroad
and didn't have the proper software.
I don't know why, I'd have to ask
(mumbles) at another
point, but we just said
when you come back to
the United States, just
do it then, that's perfectly fine.
But some of the software,
or whatever happened,
was incompatible.
And if the peer reviewer's partner didn't
upload their assignment,
obviously they can't start.
So I think it's a good idea if you
use the tool to definitely set deadlines.
We did that, encouraged the
students to actually upload.
So they're not always waiting
for their peer reviewer
to come up.
The nice thing that happens, is
on the Canvas site, you
can see who's your peer,
or who you're going to peer review
if you don't do it anonymously as well.
And then they can see if that person
has uploaded their files as well.
So that's essentially what I did
for uploading the peer review tool.
Id like to do it again
maybe in a larger scale.
I think there was only about five or six
students that actually used
it in our complete class.
But overall, I think it
was valuable for them.
They still felt like they were
part of the class, even though
they weren't physically present.
And they were still able
to do this process as well.
I imagine that you can also do it
if you wanted to have students
outside of class, right?
So just because you don't
want to do the peer review
in the class, you can use this tool
as well as an option.
So that you don't have to
devote the class time to it.
So that's it.
I'd love to take any questions.
- Could you as the instructor see all of
the comments that the
peers gave one another?
- Yes, and that's a nice thing too.
Yes, I could actually see everything
that they wrote.
So, that's great, because I can use it,
we didn't grade the actual assignment
itself, but I can actually go in
and could actually grade it in
how well they did their peer review.
And I could actually
comment upon it too as well.
So I think it's a really nice feature.
- [Audience Member] When you
comment, is that in the sidebar
or in the document?
- So you can comment directly in
the document, and then the rubric
is kind of on the side as well.
So you can kind of see,
like I can, when I go
in, I can actually see
this is what scores they
got on the actual rubric,
which is not showing right now,
and then where do they insert comments
or suggestions in the actual document.
- [Audience Member] And
that's in assignments too,
if you (mumbles) a peer thing.
They upload a Word Doc?
- Oh, on the actual assignments.
Yeah, so if you do any other type
of assignment, is it,
it's pretty much like that.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, it's pretty similar.
- [Audience Member]
Can you assign teaching
fellows the same sort of access?
- Oh, probably.
I'm assuming.
Can teaching fellows, actually at this
Canvas thing, can teaching fellows
view your entire course right?
- [Woman] They have the exact same access
as an instructor so they would be
able to see that.
- [Audience Member] Are there any plans if
you have undergraduate graders
or learning assistants?
- [Woman] We do have a role specifically
for grader, and I'm happy to talk
about that later on if you'd like
to contact me.
- Good question.
- [Audience Member] You
said there was one person
who had problems with access.
Was it in general with Canvas
or was it before, the user function for,
- The actual functions in Canvas.
So they couldn't log in to Canvas.
But again, they were abroad, so
I don't know the computer access.
And we thought it would be too
complicated to, you know,
so I told them to come back.
But it was the functions in Canvas,
so I have no idea why.
That's a good question.
- [Audience Member] I'm going to share
some of our experience (mumbles) document
Global Network Schools
in different countries.
And when our students, or students
from other business
schools around the world,
especially if they're
accessing from China,
the file doesn't always work.
So that they won't be able to use this.
- Yeah, I think that was his major issue.
He couldn't open the
actual file in Canvas.
So he couldn't see his partner's document.
Any other questions?
Thank you.
(audience clapping)
(cheerful tones)